hasta lui ha cominciato a sdraiarsi Vale
cinque sapessi Allora
speak english inglese cogna e italiano
osvertà sì nostros no no Habla español
Bueno proviamo di parlare Ah acqua sì e
ah ah sì Un bacio da un vaso una
bottiglia una bottiglia vale una
bottiglia di acqua e fria del tiempo e
si ma quanto tempo eh sì Bueno in Cargo
deve mangiare che vuole cieco crocchetta
Stefano molto buona
[Musica]
iega tortilla de patata patatas brava sì
senza la pizza la fate pizza
a chi è stata in Spagna mangia comida e
spagnola E vabbè allora proviamo questa
tortilla e le crocchette e il prosciutto
perché e quello una versione famosi
perfetto Oh ma qua la gente che si magna
lo stregona cagna cagna a me Ma come ti
permetti